bear with me I love Jesus in a mosque on
a far right radio show the artist
formerly known as Kanye West healed
Hitler sitting he saw good things about
him Dash 19. I like Hitler he said from
this influential hip-hop artist it was
the latest line in anti-Semitism but not
his last
[Music]
within hours he was on Twitter sharing
an image of a swastika inside the Star
of David
it tested the boundaries of the newly
owned social media platform he was
suspended by owner Elon Musk who called
it incitement to violence
at heart there's this idea that Jews are
somehow and obviously this is what the
Nazis believed as well as believing the
Jews are sub-human that the Jews are
somehow eating away at the fabric of
society and are able to control and
manipulate the rest of humanity in a way
that makes them alien but somehow also
you know the slave masters of the rest
of us and what that leads to is the
killing of Jews
I love this guy right here it's not so
long ago that Kanye West had Direct
access to the White House I didn't want
to put you in that position the hip-hop
artist had the affection of President
Donald Trump in office he still has his
ear
ten days ago he was a dinner guest of
trump at his Florida home in Mar-A-Lago
so was a man by the name of Nick Fuentes
they're trying to shut it down all right
here and he's a holocaust denying white
nationalists invited onto the guest list
of a contender for a second time
presidency it's a sort of Who's Who of
hate speech the sort that's crept into
the political discourse Twitter
suspension or not but the problem with
hate speech is the more that you see it
of it the more it becomes normal as you
normalize things you see evils creeping
back into society that we spent decades
trying to eradicate because we in Europe
know precisely where that kind of
rhetoric can lead President Biden has
waited on social media with a tweet of
his own posting the Holocaust happened
Hitler was a demonic figure
he said political leaders should call
out anti-Semitism and that silence is
complicity
[Music]
there is laughing through the debate
about hate its place and its platform
James Matthews Sky News Washington